[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the town of benaue it's in the
philippines it's known for two things
gorgeous rice terraces
and these amazing wooden scooters
[Music]
is
robert and the other men of benawa used
to carry rice and wood by hand up and
down the steep hills
it took forever
so they came up with the idea of using
scooters
wooden scooters
going up to speeds of 50 kilometers per
hour they're also revered as pieces of
art
[Music]
deco
every april you'll find the people of
banawe gathered together for the annual
embaya festival and its famous scooter
race
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
when you tell people that i run a slot
car
they go what what's that
i never heard of that before
when they first do it they go wow
this is fun
[Music]
i am buzz frank perry
i am the proprietor of buzzerama the
slot car racing center of the world
[Music]
slot car racing is a hobby sport that's
participated in all over the world
in 1965 it was my hobby i was one of the
first to open in new york there was 48
places like this in the city
today i'm in
i'm the lone survivor
they have 12 volt dc motors in them and
a guide flag that fits in slot and when
you hit the hand controller it energizes
those lanes
and gives the motor juice
the fastest cars can go upwards of 100
miles an hour so they're like blurs now
you have to hear them your wing wing you
can hardly see them you have to listen
to them you go
wow
kids play with computer now
and there's no interaction with anyone
over here they have interaction with
other drivers they compete they
congratulate each other you learn
sportsmanship
it's really great
just watching the cars go around the
tracks pumps up your adrenaline and you
get all excited and that that thrill
never leaves you
you always think about it
[Music]
in 1904 st louis hosted an olympic
marathon for the ages overshadowed by
the neighboring world's fair the poorly
planned event was reduced to a
lackluster sideshow primed for disaster
during a sweltering 90 degree day the
runners were thrust onto a hellish route
that cut through car traffic rocks thick
dust and 300 foot hills
of the 32 athletes who competed only 14
finished and of the 14 these are the
three worth knowing about
fred lors was a fresh-faced athlete
ready to make a name for himself for
nine miles lords was near the front of
the pack until painful muscle cramps
stopped him in his tracks yikes and he
wasn't the only one almost every single
racer had severe muscle cramps that day
thanks to this dummy chief event
organizer and amateur scientist james
sullivan you see sullivan turned the
event into an experiment to grasp how
purposeful dehydration affects athletes
immune to common sense sullivan put a
single water station at the 11th mile
mark
so for 26 miles the runners relied on
one water station that was dirty
and gave you dysentery
james sullivan what a guy oops anyway
back to lures with the sun beating down
road dusk clogging his lungs and his
muscles spazzing in protest laura's had
enough and traded in his two legs for
four wheels he hitched a car ride to the
19th mile mark got out and gingerly ran
through the finish line the crowd went
wild but before the gold medal could be
placed around his neck his ruse was
discovered
next up
andherin carbaja he was a five foot tall
cuban national and former mailman turned
athlete to get to st louis carbajal had
to raise money by competing in running
events including a 700-mile race across
cuba
once he got to st louis he was easy to
spot among the sleeveless shirts and
thigh-high shorts carbajal wore a
billowing long-sleeve shirt cut off
slacks and work boots
he didn't dress like a sports champion
but damn did he run like one
[Music]
with each and every step carbajal
charged towards the finish line even
though his legs never gave out his
grumbling stomach did
to satisfy his hunger he ate some apples
from a nearby orchard
that turned out to be rotten
so he took a little recovery nap and
then proceeded to finish in fourth place
[Music]
and then there's thomas hicks
the gold winner the top dog the champion
the barely standing living cadaver you
see hicks was so physically ill that he
couldn't cross the finish line without
the help of his trainers
why well back then stimulants were legal
and strychnine a type of rat poison was
thought to have performance enhancing
properties
so during the run his trainers gave him
small doses to gain an edge
but instead of helping him it was slowly
killing him
once hicks was dragged across the finish
line he wasn't in a cheery mood having
lost eight pounds during the race he was
a hollowed out husk of a man
the judges shrugged and gave hicks the
gold ending the nightmare
as the crowd swooned over hick's
disheveled body somewhere in the stands
james sullivan was probably sipping on a
glass of fresh water
feeling proud of putting together the
worst marathon ever
[Music]